every so often some big idea happens
but it might be one person and that idea
is in what
in the space of engineering or is it in
the space well i'll give you an example
so one of the limits of computer
performance is branch prediction
so and there's there's a whole bunch of
ideas about how good you could predict
the branch
and people said there's a limit to it
it's an asymptotic curve
and somebody came up with a better way
to do branch prediction it was a lot
better
and he published a paper on it and every
computer in the world now uses it
and it was one idea so the the engineers
who build branch prediction hardware
were happy to drop the one kind of
training array and put in another one
so it was it was a real idea and branch
prediction is
is one of the key problems underlying
all of sort of the lowest level of
software it boils down to branch
prediction
boils down to uncertainty computers are
limited by you know single thread
computers limited by two things
the the predictability of the path of
the branches and the predictability of
the
locality
of data so we have predictors that now
predict both of those pretty well
yeah so memories you know a couple
hundred cycles away local caches couple
cycles away
when you're executing fast virtually all
the data has to be in the local cache
so a simple program says you know add
one to every element in an array
it's really easy to see what the stream
of data will be
but you might have a more complicated
program that you know says get a get
element of this array look at something
make a decision
go get another element it's kind of
random and you can think that's really
unpredictable
and then you make this big predictor
that looks at this kind of pattern and
you realize well if you get this data in
this data then you probably want that
one
and if you get this one and this one and
this one you probably want that one
and is that theory or is that
engineering like the paper that was
written
was it uh asymptotic kind of kind of
discussion or is it more like here's a
hack that works well
um it's a little bit of both like
there's information theory in it i think
somewhere okay
so that's actually trying to prove yeah
but once once you know the method
implementing it is an engineering
problem
you